Schau dein Papa ist da ruft dein Helfer
dem kleinen Mädchen zu es wird in afrin
im Nordwesten von Syrien aus den
Trümmern gerettet freut und Leid liegen
so nah beieinander nach gendiris sind
Männer der umliegenden Dörfer zur Hilfe
geeilt doch für viele kam diese Hilfe zu
spät meine Mutter hat noch gelebt als
sie gerettet wurde ist dann aber
gestorben klappt dieser Mann
der Nordwesten Syriens war schon vor dem
Beben auf humanitäre Hilfe angewiesen
zudem wurden die meisten Gebäude im
Krieg beschädigt und stürzten besonders
schnell ein Millionen Familien wurden
getroffen die auf der Flucht schon
vieles verloren hatten Kälte Regen und
Schnee verschärfen die Lage im Einsatz
hier zivile Helfer der weiße Helme
die Situation ist wirklich hart es tut
sehr weh seit der ersten Stunde dieses
Bebens bitten wir um Hilfe und nichts
kommt an
das ist logistisch schwer möglich die
Straßen sind zerstört und der einzige
Grenzübergang zur Türkei ist nicht
erreichbar
notdurftig werden die Verletzten
behandelt auch im Krankenhäusern von
denen nur noch wenige Räume stehen
berichtet am Abend das iClip der
Teamchef einer Hilfsorganisation die
hier regelmäßig arbeitet und einen Tag
vor dem Beben angekommen war
medizinisches Material fehlt Matratzen
fehlen Unterkünfte Laken es gibt keinen
Strom keinen Treibstoff es fehlt
wirklich alles die Situation ist im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein Disaster
auch in der Türkei geht die Suche nach
den Opfern weiter in der Millionenstadt
hatai sind ganze Stadtviertel zerstört
internationale Hilfe ist unterwegs über
tausend Rettungskräfte hat die
Europäische Union versprochen die ersten
Helfer aus Deutschland sind gestern
eingetroffen such Trupps mit Spürhunden
der Hilfsorganisation Isa
auch in Kara man Mara Schwarten sie auf
Hilfskräfte mit bloßen Händen versuchen
die Menschen die Steine wegzuräumen und
befürchten dass alles noch viel
schlimmer wird
ob Tag oder Nacht es gibt immer wieder
Nachbeben wir leben hier in ständiger
Panik zur Zerstörung kommt nun auch noch
der Schnee den Rettern läuft die Zeit
davon der Wetterdienst hat weitere
Schneefälle vorausgesagt
ja bevor wir mit dem türkischen
Botschafter sprechen zunächst zu unserer
Korrespondentin ins Erdbebengebiet nach
Kaiser der guten Morgen Anne eine Brühl
wie ist denn die Situation heute morgen
ja guten Morgen wieder haben viele
Menschen diese bitterkalte Nacht im
Freien verbracht in ihren Autos die
Angst vor Nachbeben die ist groß die ist
hier immer wieder gibt und natürlich
laufen die Rettungsarbeiten auch weiter
weil sich ja immer noch Menschen unter
den Trümmern befinden aber man muss
sagen dass Zeitfenster diese Menschen
noch leben zu erreichen das schließt
sich so langsam und das hat natürlich
mit den eisigen Bedingungen gerade hier
zu tun die Zahl der Toten steigt weiter
in der Türkei auf jetzt
5894 Tote und es gibt noch eine andere
Zahl nämlich die von
5.575 zerstörten Gebäuden äh diese Zahl
lässt auch forschen weil sie sich seit
gestern nicht verändert hat das könnte
also heißen dass die türkischen Behörden
jetzt einen endgültigen Überblick über
das Ausmaß dieses
katastrophalen Bebens haben
eine 250 Kilometer entfernt von dir und
normalerweise drei Autostunden liegt das
Epizentrum im südanatolischen Caravan
Maras also wie ist denn dein Eindruck je
näher man dorthin kommt desto größer die
Zerstörung und desto schwieriger auch
die Hilfe
ja diesen Eindruck hatten wir in der Tat
weil wir uns gestern ja schon auf den
Weg in diese Richtung gemacht haben das
ist eine Bergregion da fährt man über
bergstraßenpässe verschneite Straßen die
Bedingungen sind sehr schwierig und
unterwegs haben wir lokale hilfs Teams
überholt die damit schweren Gerät
unterwegs waren Generatoren die Menschen
in den Dörfern haben uns gestern
Nachmittag erzählt dass sie noch keine
Hilfe bekommen haben das war ja dann
immerhin auch schon 36 Stunden nach dem
Leben inzwischen haben die lokalen
Hilfsorganisation dort in den Bergen
angefangen Zeltstädte zu errichten war
mit Decken zu verteilen essen denn
natürlich gibt es auch keinen Strom und
kein Wasser die Hilfe die kommt also
aber gerade hier kommt sie sehr langsam
live aus dem türkischen Erdbebengebiet
war das eine Brühl vielen Dank
und wir sprechen jetzt weiter mit dem
türkischen Botschafter in Deutschland
Ahmet bascharchen ist zu uns ins Studio
gekommen danke schön dass sie so früh
aufgestanden sind und Willkommen bei uns
guten Morgen Herr Botschafter ihr Land
wurde von einem Jahrhundertbeben
getroffen der türkische Präsident
erdogan hat eine siebentägige
staats-trauer ausgerufen und auch den
Notstand für die zehn betroffenen
Provinzen das ist ein Ausnahmezustand
auch für Sie hier als Botschafter und
für die entsprechenden Konsulate in
Deutschland wie arbeiten sie gerade das
ist wie sie gesagt haben eine
jahrhundert Katastrophe vielleicht
Jahrtausend Katastrophe der Ausmaß der
Zerstörung so groß dass in 10 Provinzen
fast 15 Millionen Menschen davon
betroffen sind und natürlich diese 15
Millionen Menschen haben hier in
Deutschland ihre Verbindungen mehr als 3
Millionen Menschen aus der Türkei leben
arbeiten in Deutschland und jeder hat
eine Verwandte einen Bekannten ein kommt
unter den
Opfern oder unter den Betroffenen dieser
Katastrophe und wir als die Botschaft in
Berlin als auch unsere 13
Generalkonsulate die diesen Menschen in
Deutschland dann ihre Dienste tun wir
sind natürlich sehr betroffen das ist in
unserem Land passiert ist und diese
Menschen diese drei Millionen plus
Menschen aus der Türkei fragen uns was
Sie tun können für die Betroffenen und
wie sie Informationen überhaupt bekommen
können und wie sie dann der Türkei ihrem
Heimatland oder ihrem früheren
Heimatland helfen können über die
Hilfswelle können wir gleich vielleicht
noch mal näher sprechen sie haben ja
einen direkten Draht zu Regierung haben
vielleicht auch ganz andere
Informationen was können Sie uns denn zu
den aktuellen Bergungsarbeiten und zum
Stand der Rettungsaktionen sagen in der
Türkei die Lage ist sehr schwierig das
Beben war sehr sehr stark und das sind
zwei aufeinander folgende groß mehr als
7,7 Stärke Beben gewesen und das mitten
in hoch
winterlichen Situationen in schwer
erreichbaren Gegenden der Türkei das
erschwert überhaupt das erreichen die
die Rettungsarbeiten die ja damit man
den Menschen die Hilfe bringen kann es
sind ja unglaublich viele
Hilfsorganisationen auch aus Deutschland
unterwegs in die Türkei oder sind schon
dort angekommen es gibt eine enorme
solidaritätswelle wie nehmen sie das
wahr wir bedanken uns wir sind sehr
dankbar aber das reicht leider noch
nicht aus wir haben immer noch wie man
in diesem Bericht auch gesagt hat wir
haben immer noch Möglichkeiten Menschen
aus dem Thema zu retten und das sind an
die 6000 Häuser da zerstört sind
vielleicht 1000 oder 1500 Teams die
Arbeiten aber sehr lange hier weiß an
den Trümmern die Reichen nicht noch
nicht aus wir brauchen mehr Hilfe wir
brauchen mehr Teams und wir bieten ich
bitte in den nächsten Stunden wo möglich
in die Türkei weiterhin searchitekt aus
Deutschland zu senden viele Türken leben
hier in Deutschland sie haben das gerade
angesprochen viele türkischstämmige
Menschen die sind verzweifelt haben dort
Verwandte wollen helfen fliegen
teilweise auf eigene Faust los oder
packen Hilfspakete was können Sie denen
sagen wie kann man die Menschen am
besten unterstützen die Menschen
organisieren sich in den
zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisation
hier in Deutschland die sind gut
vernetzt und unsere Generalkonsulate vor
Ort wie gesagt 13 Generalkonsulate die
helfen auch mit bei der Organisation bei
der Koordinierung dieser arbeiten wenn
die Menschen da wirklich helfen wollen
natürlich wollen sie helfen das wissen
wir sie sollten sich mit unseren
generalkonsulaten vor Ort die sie gut
kennen in Verbindung setzen was Sie tun
können wir brauchen natürlich Geld
spenden und wir brauchen Sachspenden
Geld spenden sind zuerst weil er eben
Dormann dort alles in Türkei in der
Türkei kaufen kann eine Frage zu den
Sachspenden weil es hieß das höre ich
aus den sozialen Netzwerken aber auch
von Leuten vor Ort dass man nur neue
Sachen annimmt aber brauchen die
Menschen die jetzt betroffen sind nicht
jede mögliche Hilfe gerade jede mögliche
Hilfe ja ist es gibt es wurde gebeten
dass man
wintertaugliche möglichst neue waren
mitschickt für Erwachsene wie für die
Kinder ja möglichst neu möglich okay das
ist natürlich ein Unterschied
von dieser Katastrophe ist auch der
Nordwesten von Syrien immens betroffen
und weil politisch benachteiligt kommt
dort die Hilfe nicht an die deutsche
Außenministerin hat gestern gefordert
dass die Türkei die Grenzübergänge zu
Syrien öffnen soll es gibt einen bei
Bärbel Hauer da weiß man nicht so genau
kommt der jetzt Hilfe an oder nicht das
heißt die Straßen dorthin sein komplett
zerstört wie ist ihre Position die
Türkei hilft den Syrern sowohl auf der
türkischen Seite als auf der syrischen
auf der anderen Seite der syrischen
Grenze insgesamt ca 8 bis 10 Millionen
Menschen in Syrien sowieso werden
bekommen aus der Türkei Hilfe
eine Millionen davon sind in der Türkei
als Flüchtlinge und wahrscheinlich so
ungefähr zwei Millionen Menschen aus
Syrien sind auch in diesem
Erdbebengebiet auf der türkischen Seite
aber sie haben ja die Bilder gesehen es
braucht sehr viel Hilfe und es ist
wirklich klüger wenn man mehr
Grenzübergänge öffnet und sozusagen
viele Hilfsorganisation gleichzeitig ins
Land strömen können und Solidarität
erfahren so wie ihr Land auch gerade
Solidarität erfährt ganz klar wir
solidarisieren uns auch mit dem
syrischen Volk und ganz klar die
türkische Türkei steht überhaupt nicht
davor dass man wenn man ich Hilfsgüter
von hier aus entsenden sollte dass diese
Hilfsgüter an die jüdischen Menschen
kommen dafür werden wir uns auch
einsetzen dafür werden wir auch alles
tun so wie wir aber seit Jahren tun auf
der anderen Seite der natürlichen Grenze
wie gesagt werden sehr viele Leute durch
die Türkei geholfen das ist wahr heißt
das denn dann auch das möglicherweise
Grenzübergänge noch geöffnet werden
durch die Türkei das kann ich nicht
sagen hier nach Sicherheitslage wir
müssen das dort vor Ort die türkischen
Behörden entscheiden aber das werden
bestimmt geprüft in die dieser prekären
sehr schweren Lage wir bedanken uns dass
Sie heute hier waren Herr Botschafter
wünschen ihren Landsleuten alles Gute
und bei den bergungs- und
Rettungsarbeiten maximalen Erfolg vielen
Dank für den Besuch hier bei uns ich
bedanke mich